[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans point
de vue où nous allons bien sûr revenir
sur l'attaqué qui a eu lieu ce matin
dans le 11e arrondissement de paris dans
les anciens locaux de charlie hebdo pour
parler de ce sujet mais aussi de la
crise de lakovic 19 à marseille
nous avons le plaisir d'accueillir
laurent joffrin bonsoir on vous connaît
bien sûr comme journaliste et notamment
comme jeune ancien directeur de la
rédaction de libération
mais mais vous êtes surtout désormais le
patron du mouvement engageons-nous que
vous avez créé pour faire renaître ou
pour ranimer le la gauche
social-démocrate de l'action la gauche
de l'action votre dernier livre anti
macron lettres politique a été co édité
par stoke et libération et nous
accueillons c'est jean christophe
buisson bonsoir jean christophe vous
êtes le directeur adjoint du figaro
magazine le figmag qui publie cette
semaine en couverture un dossier sur les
soldats de l'ombre ces militaires dont
on parle peu mais qui sont très actifs
surtout à l'étranger et vous êtes aussi
le présentateur de l'émission
hebdomadaire historiquement show sur la
chaîne histoire
vous avez par ailleurs codirigé avec
l'excellent guillaume tabard un ouvrage
sur les grandes figures de la droite
codirigé et ouvrage coédité par perrin
et le figaro magazine on revient dont
tabac dont tabarre absolue grande figure
absolument la droite à bas coût des je
ne sais pas mais on revient si vous le
voulez bien pour commencer sur cette
attaque qui a eu lieu en fin de matinée
rue nicolas-appert dans le 11e
arrondissement de paris au pied des
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
deux collaborateurs de l' agence de
presse première ligne ont été grièvement
blessés même si leurs jours ne semblent
ne plus être en danger
les deux principaux suspects ont été
interpellés dont un qui semble être le
responsable de l'attaqué est un
pakistanais de 18 ans évidemment cette
attente a suscité un écho tout
particulier en
un moment du procès des complices des
attentats de charlie hebdo le premier
ministre jean castex qui s'est rendu sur
place l'a rappelé
un lieu symbolique et au moment même où
se déroule le procès des auteurs des
actes indignes contre charlie hebdo
c'est l'occasion pour le gouvernement de
la république de rappeler son
attachement indéfectible à la liberté de
la presse sa volonté résolue par tous
les moyens de lutter contre le
terrorisme
et d'affirmer à la nation notre pleine
mobilisation
voilà et c'est le parquet national anti
terroriste qui a été saisie de cette
affaire
laurent joffrin même si le bilan est
heureusement beaucoup moins dramatique
que celui des attentats de janvier 2015
on a l'impression que c'est le cauchemar
qui revient c'est une
c'est une vengeance contre contre la
france c'est à dire que c'est l'effet du
fanatisme
mais c'est l'effet aussi de la
résistance c'est que le fait que charlie
hebdo et republié les dessins c'est à
susciter des menaces je sais pas si ces
menaces sont à l'origine de ce qui s'est
passé là mais enfin il ya bien des
chances je crois que c'est al qaïda qui
a lancé un mot d'ordre de d'attac contre
charlie hebdo comme charlie est bien
protégé puisque faut voir c'est
l'ensemble des institutions résiste
devait le journal lui-même qui est très
courageux tir publié les caricatures
le gouvernement pourrait dire écoutez ça
nous coûte très cher votre affaire ça
commence à suffire fait un peu moins de
provocation et puis comme ça vous ferait
oublier
pas du tout il y a
un système de protection extrêmement
efficace et qui mais fort heureusement
les gens de charlie à peu près à l'abri
de toute nouvelle tentative
j'espère parce que votre votre ancienne
maison libération avait accusé le
journaliste de chabal a été protégée ont
été les mieux protégés de france
les policiers partout avec des armes
je vais intervenir mais je ne pouvais
pas manger ou aux mitraillettes là c'est
un peu gênant la libération aurait dormi
dans un sac
enfin on se sentait protéger et puis on
a été protégée individuellement et moi
j'étais le directeur guy louis de flics
qui m'ont protégé pendant six mois et
est donc on voit que la république à
l'état en tous cas aide les journaux qui
veulent rester libre en quelque sorte et
puis l'opinion l'opinion et consensuelle
sur cette affaire
y'a pas de voix qui s'élèvent pour les a
il faut céder il faut négocier ou je ne
sais quoi personnes presque personne x
qui relativise cette résistance que que
vous ayez de l'écrire une situation que
je vais et je suis ta mine juste part
d'un point important le l'opinion
approuve les opérations militaires que
la france a mené plusieurs
en afghanistan et en irak en séries il y
en a à ce moment au mali l'opinion est
d'accord avec ça personne ne dit mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire c'est payé là
c'est une folie pas du tout les gens
disent en lutte contre l'islamisme
on y va bah c'est là où j'ai pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous on lutte mais en
ut pas globalement quand vous voyez
qu'aujourd'hui encore des gens comme
isabelle rhazoui sont obligés d'être
protégés sont en permanence menacés
quand vous voyez les menaces qui a eu
sur la drh justement de charlie wi et
quelques jours qu'on est obligé
d'exfiltrer en permanence hariqa près
temps quand vous voyez dans la misson
d'anna qui explique quand même sur le
dos ils mettent de l'huile sur le feu et
que tout ça n'est pas il ya quand même
plein de voix discordantes qui dit il
exagère à charlie hebdo pour ses
politiques de cyril et ça ça m'a jamais
appelé mais pardon il y a des centaines
de milliers de gamins qui regardent avec
pas seulement mais surtout des humains
qui regardent et nous lasser l'opinion
et dont est qui et qui ensuite il ya eu
un sondage approuvant ce qu'il avait dit
en disant que franchement charlie hebdo
il exagérait vous avez ça et d'un autre
côté pour ne pas pour ne pas j'ai pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous quand
vous dites l'état fait tout ce qu'il
peut l'état si si on part du principe
que l'état c'est aussi le prénom la
public et c'est aussi par exemple le
conseil constitutionnel au mois d'août
dernier
il ya une loi qui est un projet de loi
qui était présenté une loi de
surveillance judiciaire qui a été
retoquée par le conseil constitutionnel
c'était le 7 août deux jours après huit
humanitaires étaient tués au niger dont
6 françaises la fois du procès non est
ce que je vous dis je vous laisse en
parallèle ces cas menace on sait
qu'elles existent depuis 2015 on sait à
l'époque de hollande je crois que 45
attentat déjoué depuis 2000 17 30
attentat déjoué ce qu'a dit darmana fin
août
donc on sait que la menace qu donc
continuer à exister et pourtant vous
avez un président de la république qui
repousse à la fin 2021
la loi sur les séparatismes la loi sur
l'islamisme en fait mon fils veut pas
dire le nom très bien en france
simplement que c'est ça le sujet vous
avez conseil constitutionnel qui retoque
une loi de surveillance judiciaire
moi j'ai pas l'impression qu'il ya
unanimité de cette résistance tant au
niveau de l'état qu'au niveau de
l'opinion pour ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure on peut renverser
ça fait partie de la résistance le fait
de dire on est un état de droit on lui
mais il ya des lois moyens comme ray des
lois répressives enfanta il existe on
peut les appliquer à garder à l'oeil
oui et non parce que c'est peut-être pas
les oies qui est très difficile
d'éradiquer le terrorisme n'est pas
simple il faut des moyens policiers
considérable il faut les en omettre l
angle et c'est ça le plus efficace
derrière où il faut faire les opérations
et par exemple comme ça pareil des
théories ce sont des étrangers en
situation régulière ça c'est une
pastilla éradiquer sans en jambes l'état
de droit il me semble il suffit que
d'appliquer la loi ça l'est mais
renvoyés chez eux
ce qu'on ne fait pas on va voir ce
pakistanais de 18 ans comment il
arrivait dans quelles conditions on en
fait un joli et ce qui était français
est-ce qu'ils étaient ensemble et enfin
tranquille ben ouais mais apparemment ça
suffit pas puisque ont en effet encore
qui fondent et qui commettent des
attentats sur notre sol donc jeux
sociaux dans les pays qui sont beaucoup
plus répressif que nous c'est pas je
m'intéresse plus à mon pays que vous
devrez pas quand même le fait d'empiler
des lois il faut les appeler bah oui je
suis d'accord on essaye de les appliquer
c'est vrai mais je suis pas sûr qu'elle
soit plus compliqué en plus
soyons cyniques et un bras la plupart
des terroristes qui ont commis des
attentats ont été tuées pas
volontairement m'enfin les policers
forcément dans le cadre de la loi
d'ailleurs la police si vous lisez le
second magazine de ce week end des
opérations clandestines où on tue
apparemment des méchants j'ai pas de
sens à voir vraiment ce qu'on appelle
les pure de la république
on va du pays mais jeremy jeffress pas
encore eu donc nos lois mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que les démocraties ont
dû elles sont faibles sont décadente
n'arrive pas tout ça c'est pas tout à
fait vrai hélas si je peux faire un
petit dégagement d'une minute si on
prend du recul
le terrorisme échoue en général
si vous faites un siècle de terrorisme
puisque nous a si ce que j'ai fait la
plupart des terrorismes ont échoué ça
dure le problème c'est que ça dure en
géant une génération
j'avais une génération terroriste par
exemple les basques par exemple oui
néerlandais par exemple les terroristes
italiens pendant les années de plomb etc
c'est à dire une génération où ce très
long mais à la fin c'est raté il
n'arrive pas alors leurs objectifs
politiques
je met une nuance à ce que vous dites je
précise que vous êtes tous les deux
journalistes et historiens échouent
souvent souvent lorsqu'ils n'ont plus le
support d'un pays où d'un système ou
d'un système national le terrorisme
d'extrême gauche d'un incendie ça n'est
ni par échoué parce que le mur
le mur de berlin est tombé le comice est
effondrée le syndicat les irlandais mais
j'arriverai les irlandais ils ont le
soutien d'une partie de leur domicile
sauf qu'ils s'arrêtaient soutien quand
ils les accords de paix donc c'était
terminé il y avait plus un louis saïa
puis le guerrier adams qui était au
pouvoir c'est parce que je veux dire par
là c'est que l'islamisme aujourd'hui
l'islamisme
oui mais les mythes d'islamisme
aujourd'hui bénéficie de soutiens d'état
d'état officielle d'état nationaux et il
vous parle pas de l'état du califat 2-1
le pakistan par exemple tiens parlons du
pakistan puisque ce jeune homme semble
venir du pakistan le pakistan
aujourd'hui c'est un pays qui a mis en
prison une jeune fille asia bibi pendant
neuf ans parce qu'elle avait bu dans un
tuyau dans un puits qui était soi disant
réserver c'est pas moi qui vais les
militants et quel était cannelle les
plus grandes manifestations contre
charlie hebdo venaient du pakistan c'est
un mode les grandes manifestations ces
grandes mobilisations populaires
aujourd'hui encore vous avez deux
millions de chrétiens au pakistan sur
une population de 100 et quelques
millions qui ce qui est stigmatisé qui
est considéré comme une sous population
et ça c'est un état officielle avec toi
dès ce que je bats cette non parce que
je vis a mis son joli bénéficient ils
allaient sous de l'aide sont encore
d'état alors que tous les terroristes
qu'on évoquait tout à l'heure et nos
amis aux codes examen droite ou
d'extrême gauche soutient ben oui ils
n'existent plus parce qu'il n'a pas de
soutien d'états orly sa mission lui la d
etat officielle avec beaucoup de moyens
beaucoup d'argent qui a mal paru sur ce
je vous donne les roms il aboutit pas du
tout à ces élus qui pour l'instant mais
créer un califat il a été dégommé et
après ils font du terrain et dégommer
dit ça aux soldats français au mali ils
ont pas sûr qu'il soit dégommant s'est
déplacé oui celui là c'est arrivé j'ai
déplacé
oui d'accord oui mais la menace est là
vous avez allumé ridan il ressurgit d'al
qaïda et elle était doublée par par des
jeunes d'un seul coup c'est le concerné
poil de la bête sans salle du manège
comment ça dure au moins une génération
c'est ça qui est terrible
je vous donne des réactions de nos
internautes les canaux ne manquent pas
pour vous exprimer vous avez youtube
vous avez facebook vous avez le
figaro.fr vous avez bien sûr twitter
avec le hashtag point de vue scolaire
plus sur youtube nous dit y avait-il
encore une protection policière devant
les anciens locaux de charlie je
compense je crois pas non même si
effectivement il y avait plus de raison
puisque comme vous on vous le disait les
la rédaction de charlie hebdo a déménagé
mais dans des lieux qui sont tenus
secrets donc que personne ne connaît
sylvie je trouve ce geste lamentable il
faut renforcer la justice qui est trop
permissive en france
et puis d'autres réactions celle de cimb
asie sur youtube terminé le qu'ovide
place aux terroristes pour
l'interrogation n'est ce pas un moyen
d'étouffer l'un de l'autre alors c'est
peut-être l'effet obtenu mais on peut
pas dire évidemment qui est une
attention naturellement on est d'accord
ça s'appellerait du complotisme modèle
elle y est toujours sur facebook avec
les moyens d'aujourd'hui
s'il ya des menaces écrites on devrait
pouvoir remonter à ces personnes et
pouvoir les identifier les neutraliser
pourquoi on anticipe ah c'est vrai qu'un
certain nombre en attendre de
journalistes dont notre consoeur julie
devant rob ont fait l'objet de menaces
de mort sur les réseaux sociaux
je les ai portés à la police mais une
fois que vous avez le papier que vous
faites du vigile
on peut pas retrouver les auteurs
c'était un papier papier pardon mais
c'est compliqué
ce qui me semble très très con votes
complexes dans cette histoire c'est que
manifestement 18 ans pakistanais il va
là où il sait qu'il ya vait charlie
hebdo mais je pense que ça se trouve il
ne sait même pas qu'il ya plus charlie
hebdo ici sait même pas que charlie
hebdo c'est déjà ça fait partie de ces
gens qui sont cons qui sont pas vraiment
des loups solitaires parce qu'ils sont
influencés par ailleurs une arme de
boucher donc on voit bien que c'est pas
une occasion c'est pas la laisser pas
l'attentât du bataclan wild oats imiter
voilà si vous voulez oui je sais pas
comment l'appeler mais mais mais mais
pas falip à moi n'est pas moins grave
parce que les deux blessés auraient pu
être tués il y aura plus de morts après
c'est ça qui est difficile à contrôler
pour un état de droit effectivement
c'est ces gens là qui sont influencés
par l'ambiance par les réseaux sociaux
par des noms qu'on n'arrive pas à
contrôler il me semble pas que la lutte
contre l'islamisme sur internet soit
engagée de manière assez fort qu'on voit
encore passer des chaussures les sur les
réseaux sociaux qui devraient être
interdits proscrite par la loi il ya
tout le dark web qui fonctionne et je ne
vois pas comment les démocraties peuvent
sans enjambées effectivement une forme
de d'état de droit avec la surveillance
parvenir à éradiquer cet islamisme qui
est maintenant imprégnées et qui est
relayée ou tatis mutandis par des gens
qui encore une fois relativise en disant
mais charlie hebdo exagère vous émouvoir
zemmour produits ce qui produit une
forme de haine contre ses discours là
qui devrait cesser aussi on aurait
commencé par là et je pense ça fait
partie des moyens de lutte contre contre
l'islamisme d'être solidaires quand on a
fait cet tous les journaux sauf la sp
pour des raisons qui n'ont évoqué a fait
7 7 7 pages de publicité pour la liberté
d'expression il ya un mot qu'on
n'emploie jamais dans cette page nous
mêmes c'est l'islamisme
je crois que tant qu'on ne paie pas ce
mot là en face de la réalité
on n'arrivera pas à éradiquer l'islam
non mais l'incontournable c'est un
constat je voudrais vous poser la
question laurent joffrin la même voie
les internautes
craignez-vous une augmentation de la
menace terroriste après l' attaque à
paris près des anciens locaux de charlie
hebdo
les internautes sont très partagés et si
oui mais à 51% et vous est-ce que vous
pensez que objectivement le niveau de
menaces monte ça peut monter même mieux
possible
c'est possible parce que encore une fois
le moralement psychologiquement le
beaucoup de français en tout cas
voyageurs qui sont faibles ou plus il
anime mais beaucoup de français
ne sais tu pas cette fois voilà protéger
la vie pareille ils défendent la liberté
de la presse ils défendent la liberté
ils défendent leur état qui est
démocratique etc
ils pensent ils croient ses valeurs à
partir de là ça en fait des cibles ont
fait des cibles
un dernier mot sur cette affaire selon
nos confrères de bfm tv
le principal suspect a reconnu les faits
à la police évidemment vous suivez sur
le site du figaro les derniers mots il
sera intéressant de voir s'il a fait
allégeance à qui est ce qu'elle est ce
que cette solitaire ou au pas ou est ce
que ça va être récupérés ou non c'est ça
qui va être intéressant récupérer ou
revendiquées je propose de parler d'un
autre sujet qui n'a rien à voir vous
vous souvenez
c'était jeu olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé
pardon avait annoncé la fermeture des
bars et des restaurants à marseille et à
nice pour des raisons évidemment
sanitaire c'est un véritable tollé qui
avait accueilli cette décision du coup
le ministre est allé cet après midi sur
place
et voici ses premières déclarations ils
l'affirment
non on ne stigmatise pas les marseillais
je crois que chacun doit comprendre
l'importance du mémo pour marseille et
pour les autres territoires qui sont
concernés il s'agit pas de pointer une
ville un département plutôt qu'un autre
j'aurais certainement pas choisi
marseille étant moi même fils de
marseillais petit fils de marseillais
j'aime tellement cette ville donc il ne
faut certainement pas y voir j'ai voulu
boire ça il a traîné des symboles ou des
volonté de stigmatiser la ville c'est
totalement totalement hors de propos
ce que nous disons c'est que chacun doit
comprendre que nous devons freiner
absolument la circulation du virus
rapidement parce que sinon je peux vous
garantir ce que j'ai dit il ya un mois
aux élus à la préfecture je leur ai dit
vous refusez les mesures de gestion
refusé les mesures de couvre feu c'est
compliqué d'avancer
vous ne croyez pas la menace est là je
pense que dans quelques semaines
ça va augmenter dans les hôpitaux je
vous le dis je suis pas ni un oracle et
nine cassandre mais hélas et vous
entendez ce que disent les scientifiques
c'est eux qui guide la politique que
nous menons sur la base des courbes
qu'il vous présente qui sont hélas la
plupart du temps même jusqu'à présent
tout le temps vérifiez donc nous devons
agir maintenant pour ne pas prendre des
mesures plus dures et plus dont nous
agissons moins longtemps nous aurons
besoin d'agir jean christophe vissant il
vous convainc le ministre rien une
phrase qui m'a sidéré que ce sont les
scientifiques qui dicte la politique va
l'aveu est là ce sont les scientifiques
qui dicte la politique gouvernementale
c'est normal en matière de santé
publique non non non non les
scientifiques donnent leur avis puis un
moment donné on fait de la politique on
gouverne on décide et ce que les
scientifiques donnent leur avis oui
exactement répondu les halles avouer que
c'est les scientifiques c'est quand même
extraordinaire
je pense qu'il est pas allé de gaîté de
coeur et que
on le fait comprendre qu'il serait bien
qu'ils y aillent sur les mon avis c'est
emmanuel macron qui a forcé olivier
ferrand essayé de lui avoir une
explication de gravure parce que il est
d'autant plus coupable de sa part de ne
pas avoir communiqué en amont avec les
autorités locales marseillais avec les
préfets avec les élus chose que jean
castex élus du territoire et dieu sait
s'il a répété à avait promis on dit
maintenant on travaille sur place avec
les élus un prévenir une demi heure
avant qu'il va faire cette annonce est
d'autant plus coupable qui est lui-même
le revendique d'être enfin est fils de
marseillette petit-fils de marseille est
donc c'est encore plus incompréhensible
d'avoir raté sa gouverner c'est prévoir
et c'est aussi communiquer il n'a ni
prévu ni communiqué ne pas prévoir
l'impact cette décision peut être
justifiée d'un point de vue sanitaire
aurait qu'est ce qui l'empêché il dit le
27 août j'ai des prévenus entre le 27
août et le 24 septembre il me semble qui
s'est passé un mois il pouvait il ya
quinze jours dire attention je vais
prévenu fait quelque chose ça va mal
finir là on a vraiment l'impression
effectivement la provence citerai la
punition c'est complètement erratiques
com com communication
j'ai l'impression que c'est aussi pour
se dédouaner de tous les responsabilités
qui relève du gouvernement depuis des
mois sur les masques sur les tests sur
les sur les lits qui n'ont pas été
rajouté alors ils sont promis maintenant
l'impression qu'à chaque fois il faut
une catastrophe pour qui il ya eu six
mois quand même pour réaménager
l'hôpital avec céline rémy nation c'est
la même situation qui a six mois alors
qu'on alors que c'est lui même qui nous
disaient qu'il y aurait une deuxième
vague
c'est assez assez compliqué c'est assez
courageux de sa part de la part d' aller
à marseille même si c'est sur ordre
mais encore une fois un aveu d'échec et
un aveu de des responsabilités en dix
ans et les scientifiques qui nous
gouvernent sous-entendu vous savez moi
je fais ce qu'on me dit de faire
c'est incroyable je crois qu'ils ont
fait une boulette ça me paraît manifeste
moi qui suis plutôt favorable aux
mesures de précaution en matière
sanitaire en tout cas depuis le début de
la crise une boulette parce que
ils n'ont pas dit la vérité lui on y va
on s'est concerté et s'est concerté il
ya un mois mais quand on dit il faut il
aurait fallu nous prévient il fallait
prévenir des mesures pas seulement de
dire savez la situation est difficile
sans doute mais dire voilà on va prendre
telle mesure peut-être qu'elle vous
plairont pas discute on est ce qu'on
peut les amodiés d'une manière ou d'une
autre et c
ils n'ont pas fait du tout ça tombe
comme a dit maire-adjoint payan ça tombe
comme une pierre d'un pont sur la ville
qui offre maintenant obéissent et en
plus ils ne mesurent pas le degré de
désespoir économique et social qu'il ya
dans la profession de la restauration et
des bars et parce que ce sont des gens
qui ont été confinés plus longtemps que
les autres
souvent c'est des petites entreprises
qui n'ont pas de trésorerie et la mort
économique c'est pas la mort physique
d'accord mais enfin c'est quand même
très difficile à supporter or il ya un
tiers de ces gens là qui sont menacées
de disparition écrit mais quand même
c'est à dire moi je connais bien la
situation j'ai des propriétaires dans ma
famille il lance un bar restaurant ou de
deux mois on arrête tout pendant deux
mois plus d'argent alors il ya des prêts
mais les presse il faut les rembourser
donc ils savent déjà qu'ils devront dans
les deux ans qui viennent ils devront
travailler pour rembourser un prêt ces
détails qui ne toucheront pas de salaire
alors qu'ils font je pourrais me 60
heures par semaine et donc c'est des
gens qui se lancent dans la vie c'est
ils ont leur vie devient un mur quand
ils ont un mur devant eux au moins deux
ans d'efforts pour rien rien du tout et
alors qu'ils n'y sont présents ils ont
essayé d'appliquer les mesures barrières
en plus il ya un argument technique
c'est que c'est les restaurateurs sont
assez malins pour le faire remarquer
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas faire venir
les gens dans des bars et des
restaurants avec des mesures avec un
encadrement qui est celui des salariés
qui sont là et qui sont donc essaye de
faire leur travail plutôt que de laisser
se développer des des regroupements
sauvage comme j'en ai vu hier soir dans
ma rue en plein paris des gens qui
étaient là en train de boire
il était 20 sans masque comme une espèce
de provocation pour les radios on
continue à aller dans les bars alors
qu'elle ait pas de bar c'est pour ça que
c'est d'autant plus compréhensive et que
la colère des restaurateurs et de
marseille d'autant que légitime que
l'affolement où la panique qui n'est pas
forcément justifié selon certains
médecins d'ailleurs certains sont
fidèles
là on est en train d'inventer sur un
plateau on était peut-être en train de
redescendre le point d'incidence tout ça
est assez complexe mais l'idée c'est que
aujourd'hui les clusters c'est en
famille ou seul et où sur les lieux de
travail dit que l'affolement vient du
fait que maintenant c'est à nouveau les
personnes âgées qui sont concernés à
l'heure pendant cet été on a bien vu
c'était plutôt les jeunes qui étaient
concernés les jeunes souffrent moins de
l'aco vite que les personnes âgées
sauf que les personnes âgées elles vont
pas dans les bars après 22 heures
c'est chez elle c'est parce que les
jeunes vont après voir les personnes
âgées et leurs familles donc si on est
assez jeune vous continuez dans les bars
mais n'allez pas voir vos grands parents
dans l'est dans les deux prochains mois
ça me paraît plus cohérent que fermer le
bar c'est d'autant que les jeunes vont
quand même aller voir leur branche enfin
c'est ça qui est pas compréhensible dans
cette communication et qui sont vraiment
rire atik vous disiez l'enjeu fera que
tout ça avait manqué de concertation
mais on peut se poser la question est ce
que la concertation aurait changé
quelque chose à la colère des élus
regardez par exemple celle de samia
ghali qui est 2e adjointe divers gauche
sur la mairie de marseille
elle a carrément expliqué c'était avant
la venue d'olivier vérone
penser qu'elle n'a pas changé d'avis
depuis elle a carrément expliqué que la
police municipale ne ferait pas respecté
cette interdiction
la police municipale ne verbalisera pas
les restaurants et les bars ouverts la
police municipale à d'autres missions
savez je préférerais que demain la
police nationale soit là où elle doit
être là où il ya des riches où on a des
problèmes avec des rodéos sauvages qui
sont pas malheureusement maîtriser
aujourd'hui sur la ville les problèmes
de cambriolages les problèmes de
stupéfiants
plutôt que d'aller verbaliser des
commerçants qui essaient de gagner leur
vie et faire marcher l'économie
française laurent joffrin vous la
comprenez où c'est du clientélisme
rapidement difficiles à contrer un nom
en revanche conclu
quand elle dit la police municipale ne
fera pas respecter la loi c'est quand
même choquant et l'union oui sur le
principe il a tort d'accord mais c'est
connu défenseur plus virulents de l'état
de droit mais non mais je comprends moi
la détresse de ces gens là bas c'est
vrai que la police municipale
il ya un côté patriotique patriotisme de
ville donc les policiers de la ville
vont être obligés de les verbaliser les
leurs copains pratiquement plus
fréquentes
alors j pas tous les jours qu'on m'a plu
policiers passent leur temps dans les
bars bien mais mais quand même ils les
connaissent bien
donc ils n'ont pas envie de les
verbaliser c'est difficile et c'est un
symptôme c'est que la vente
l'hypothèse c'est que la société
française est en train de mettre en
balance les dégâts causés par le lakovic
19 et les dégâts causés par la lutte
contre le co2 qui est un dilemme
tragique parce que vous avez d'un côté
il ya des morts on compte tous les jours
à juste titre d'ailleurs et de l'autre
côté il ya les morts qu'on ne compte pas
et qui est ce on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
ne sont pas soignées parce que ce ne
sont pas soignées pour les mêmes raisons
mais surtout ceux qui sont les victimes
de la crise sociale
on sait que quand il ya une augmentation
du chômage ça crée des effets sanitaires
néfastes aux nuisibles et ça ce n'est
pas quand ça n'est pas comptabilisé donc
est elle beaucoup de gens on le voit
d'ailleurs dans le succès de cette
provocation de caen il s'appelle nicolas
bedos donc là au début il ya des gens
qui ont dit ça
les philosophes qui a publié un tweet en
dix ans laissez nous vivre et lierait
nous embrasser et tant pis si on meurt
c'est aussi ça la vie
oui ou dans le succès du livre de bhl
qui est un peu dans le même esprit où
nous concevons ville et on n'a pas ce
livre mais en tout cas là on ne peut pas
en ville depuis le début dit ça personne
ne l'écoutait et j'ai l'impression
maintenant que ce discours c'est qu'elle
celui de la vie et du risque pour vous
résumer la vie est pas de risque dont il
faut prendre des risques
ce discours là commence à prendre de la
consistance parce que les gens sont
confrontés à une mort économique déjà là
qu'elle crée aussi des questions mais la
vie et de mort tout court il me semble
que vous ne devriez pas prendre à la
légère en dix ans elle a tort on passe
ce qui est en train de se passer je
pensais beaucoup plus grave que ça quand
vous avez des élus de tous bords
oui l'extrême gauche à l'extrême droite
de petites villes et de villages de
grandes villes qu'ils font nous ferons
ce qu'ils appellent à une fronde montre
paris contre l'état alors c'est
marseille c'est la vieille rivalité
marseille paribas depuis le foot mais
depuis la peste en provence en 1720 où
on a quasiment fermé enfin louis 15 a
fait ériger un mur pour éviter que les
marseillais viennent contaminer avec la
casi lunettes syrie le reste du pays je
caricature un peu mais les marseillais
ont ça en mémoire bien évidemment quand
vous avez toute une région comme ça
qu'ils se mobilisent unanimement contre
l'état ça peut avoir valeur d'exemple
pour les autres régions lorsque deux
aveyron va annoncer que bat toulouse
aussi à lille aussi en bretagne aussi il
faut prendre les mêmes mesures d'avoir
vu des élus qui libérait cette parole de
contestation de refus du consentement de
l'ordre sanitaire dictée de paris je
pense qu'on se prépare des jours très
difficiles en allemagne en a vu il y
avait des manifestations de citoyens
contre le port du masque c'était des
citoyens lambda là c'est pas des
citoyens
c'est vraiment c'est il ya même des
médecins et des médecins des élus et là
je pense qu'il ya quand même une crise
politique qui s'amorce et peut-être plus
grave qu'on est content c'est un
basculement les règles d'accord avec moi
oui c'est ça le basculement le ministre
de la santé olivier veyrat en fait il
trop en se déplaçant à marseille vous
êtes 72% à répondre oui
plusieurs réactions celle de john sur
youtube honnêtement fermer les bars de
semaine est complètement nul c'est de
l'amateurisme
et puis beaucoup de réactions sur les
tests aussi celle de file toujours sur
youtube qui nous dit que les tests
devraient se faire à domicile sur
demande à marie qui voudrait arrêter au
contraire les tests inutile disant que
c'est beaucoup d'argent perdu et puis
julien comme il est devenu de règles de
se porter sur tous les points chauds
vers on a déjà fait trop avec le
confinement général il refait presque la
même boulette à marseille interdite du
chloroquine et maintenant ils essaient
de se rattraper puis aussi cette
réaction de file sur youtube pendant la
soirée catastrophique de la coupe
d'europe de foot on a vu comment à
marseille
la distanciation n'étaient pas
respectées ils étaient très nombreux
pourquoi se plaindre maintenant ça c'est
un argument quand même laurent joffrin
c'est en gros les marseillais pas pardon
d'être un peu triviale mais ils ont
déconné et donc du coup les indicateurs
sanitaires sont pas bons et c'est une
sorte pas de punition mais juste de
moyens d'endiguer leur irresponsabilité
vrai ou faux il fait il faudrait prouver
que les marseillais sont plus
irresponsable que les autres donc on va
juste un cliché je ne sais pas si c'est
un cliché montre que ce n'est en tout
cas plus plus rebelle c'est une
impression et non c'est pas moi j'ai vu
à paris j'ai vu beaucoup de gens qui
mettait pas de masque qui était très
proche
pendant l'été c'était très étaient
légion n'hésitez pas à marseille donc
c'est difficile à dire du coup on va au
risque de tomber exactement dans ce que
les marseillais reproche c'est à dire
vous visez les préjugés contre nous tous
si souvenez-vous il ya quelques années
on avait failli mettre marseille sous
tutelle quand il ya eu l'histoire de la
rue d'aubagne je crois les mêmes us
défendre et donc ils ont charmé mois
encore une fois sans remonter à 17,120
comme j'ai fait tout à l'heure mais
l'idée que quand même sont des grands
enfants qui font parfois n'importe quoi
paris on est un peu obligé de temps en
temps le leur rappeler les choses alors
à gaudin va vous mettre sous tutelle si
vous continuez à pas vous occuper des
quartiers insalubres là aujourd'hui
donc il ya ce sentiment qui imprègne les
marseille certains ça parce qu'on va
revenir là des éléments du discours ou
de l'analyse du mouvement des gille et
joli c'est à dire baril ne comprenant
pas les territoires une révolte qui
vient du bas et qu'on n'a pas vu venir
on va voir si il se passe la même chose
il ya le côté on a raison
rationnellement
donc vous ne pouvez pas vous n'avez pas
d'arguments voilà nous opposer et ça ça
énerve les gens
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
merci elle nous avoue pardon de nous
avoir suivi un petit coup de chapeau à
la première livraison de la newsletter
du figaro magazine vous n'y est pas pour
rien cher jean christophe buisson qui
vous permet de retrouver toutes les
pépites de votre magazine préféré
merci bull et bon week-end à lundi
[Musique]